[Musique]
ah oui parce que l'église est un couteau
comme ça très bien malgré lui plus du
tout maintenant lundi dont pas toujours
savoir comment comics et des couteaux le
cuisinier dans un usine
si les 10 des couteaux de cette façon
c'est à dire j'entendais une alarme qui
chante contre le suivi et le boucher le
boucher qui vit au plo à l'étalagé
les clientes autour de lui il église
comme sa cuisine à la mi course
oui attention ne pas lâcher par cette
somme est fait on va faire un jambon au
raifort c'est à dire c'est un jambon cru
et pour l'agrémenter lui enlever un peu
de sel ont fait une sauce crème avec du
raifort dedans c'est à dire que quand on
mange le jambon avec cette crème et
leurs efforts s'adoucit et les meilleurs
derrière cette étrange on va faire un
coco aucun cas un coq au vin c'est à
dire on va le faire avec du vin
beaujolais oui oui qu'est ce qu'il faut
pour faire le coq au vin il faut des
petits oignons de l'ail une échalote 1
bouquet garni du lard du lard salé mais
non fumé avant larissa les uns aux
fumées ont fondé par trop salée non plus
des champignons 250 g de champignons
bien sûr je n'avais les champignons des
bois on peut mettre des chanterelles on
peut mettre ont pu remplir et les
champignons de paris par n'importe quel
autre champignon
bon il faut une carotte 1 oignon 1
poulet bien sûr si un poulet qui fasse
kg 8 à 2 kg pour combien de personnes
or bien pour six couverts toujours 12h06
couvert et du beaujolais bien sûr deux
bouteilles de beaujolais parce que on va
faire le font en même temps on maintient
notre coq au vin et après on va faire
les crêpes
c'est à dire que les crêpes vous
comprenez la chandeleur est pas loin
on va faire qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
faire les crêpes il faut un demi litre
de lait 1 milite de lait cru entier
entier et à ses 250 g de farine
oui quatre of wwii 250 g de beurre des
sols au temple de famille oui il faut
autant de beurre côte farine que
d'ailleurs je m'en vais
m légèrement à fond déjà sur le coin du
fourneau pour qu'il soit plus facile à
travailler
une pincée de sel et deux cuillères
sucre vous voyez maintenant les
volailles dans le temps on les passait à
l'eau de vie de vin c'est à dire on
faisait flamber pour enlever les petits
poils mais maintenant de la façon qu'il
l'est plus il est plus me la paraffine
on a même plus d'uv c'est formidable et
poêlée c'est à dire alors on coupe le
goudron de petits bouts ici on va couper
l'autre il faut faire avec
il faut faire attention non mais il faut
faire attention à l'est vous allez vous
en occuper un peu faire fondre le beurre
allez faites fondre le beurre doucement
et qui soit presque noisette
alors la volaille début on va couper le
comble a c'est à dire on prend le coup
dessus
ici on coupe les pattes et là on va
commencer à vider la wilaya pour vider
la volaille on enlève le jabot c'est le
jabot où il ya les graines de maïs
d'ailleurs quand un poulet bien nourrie
on doit trouver les graines de jabot en
décolle les poumons qui sont le long des
côtes bien les décoller là on ouvre
l'arrière c'est à dire il faut l'ouvrir
comme il faut pour bien enlever le
croupion là hélas ce moment là on doit
enlever le tout c'est à dire on va avoir
le foie
on va voir les poumons et le coeur voyez
donc c'est à peu près bien vite et les
maintenant on va être découpée notre
volailles pour découper la volaille
voilà découpé en huit mois cherche la
hiace presse qu'elle a dû s'occuper de
la recette des crêpes
j'ai bien dit 250 g de farine voilà les
205 g de farine et vous avez pour qu'une
pâte à crêpes ne fasse pas de grumeaux
ça c'est très important parce que bien
souvent les pâtes à crêpes temps des
grumeaux pour réussir la pâte à crêpes
du premier coup il faut mélanger d'abord
mettre la farine et mélanger le lait de
da ah bon et le lait froid et donc si
vous mélangez le lait la farine
si votre farine était passé au tamis
avant vous avez aucun
rumeau une fois que c'est fait cette
réforme va laisser ça va bien on va vous
charest s'est dit inquiet mettre sur le
côté là voilà ici laissé ici voilà voilà
mais voir explique bien là parce
qu'après vous me direz j'ai pas compris
en ligue 2 alors la farine 1 200 g de
farine un demi litre de lait voilà alors
vous voyez les gens vous avez une porte
qui est lisse là dedans vous avez
rajouté quatre chantiers
vous voyez que si vous aviez mélanger
vos oeufs dans la farine des pieds sur
votre trouva landais c'était des
grumeaux donc singles d'efforts c'était
loupé quatre fa la la farine le lait le
lait et les 6es et là maintenant vous
remuez donc avec le tennis même un
enfant de cette attention que il faut
que le leicester square ya 3 pourra pas
bien voire froid et voyez vous avez
aucun grumeaux un témoin alors vous
mettez deux cuillères de sucre
voyez c'est le sucre j'ai écrit sucre
pour me tromper en deux cuillères pour
moi de vous laver deux tuyaux dessus de
cuir du chlore et puis là vous mettez
une pincée de sel
une pincée et vous savez que vous faire
de la bonne pâtisserie
moi je suis d'avis de salé toutes les
pâtisseries parce que la petite pointe
de 16 a fait ressortir dans le v6 pour
l'envoyer donc cela dès maintenant nous
avons notre bois font du cayla et non
250 g de beurre et nous allons mélangés
dans l'appareil
les 250 g de beurre et alors je vous
expliquer davantage une fois qu'on a
fait ça il ya plus de 1 2 m de beurre
dans les poils c'est à dire que le
beurre est entièrement dans la porte
alors donc voyez vous avez une pâte qui
est juste comme il faut
telle avantages d'une pâte à crêpes ses
pouvoirs de la sphère deux heures avant
pour qu'elle repose elle repeint ma
grand-mère de l'état à l'envoyer
maintenant la pâte à crêpes foule à brax
thackeray bar pause on ne s'ennuie plus
on va le laisser dans un endroit
légèrement show pas trop chaud mais
légèrement et maintenant on va déclinant
les volailles
alors notre voie là et on va mettre la
cocotte au chaud et on va découper la
volaille en huit morceaux le coup parce
que le coup c'est agréable
bon mais plus chez les petits oignons
déjà un
alors pour couper la volaille ont fait
la cuisse là vous permettez qu'elle à la
cuisse ou la détacher bien pour aller
jusqu'au bout 1
et on va cuire la volaille avec sa
carcasse et ça va nous servir de fond la
halle ici là il faut bien bien marquer
lé elle jusqu'au bout ici voilà l'autre
cuisse
il n'y a pas de neige vous aviez assez
pour les jeunes voilà l'autre aileron
ici là l envoyer ça me fout les découper
en règle mais moi je vais vous dire si
vous n'avez pas découper un poulet comme
ça où le découper comme vous savez il
n'y a pas de problème pour moi un poulet
vous pouvez le découper ya pas
d'importance en laissant les autres pas
un massacre et non pas le massacrer mais
le coupé comme vous le pensez en huit
petits morceaux au mois pour faire un
bon poulet sauté
finalement un coq au vin cela poulet
sauté puisqu'on le fait avant il faut
pas que les poulets sont trois gros et
laissait toujours les hausses avec donc
moi je coupe le poulet 1 règle ça pour
les professionnels parce qu'après ils
iront lokuge ne s'est pas coupé un
poulet combien d'heures on a les yves ça
pourra faire pour demain
voilà hélas la cuisson 2 bon alors
maintenant la carcasse on va la mettre
dedans le sol il est est ce que c'est
que le sol il laisse les deux petits
fils est qu'ils sont là chaque côté
c'était hier
oui et vous savez le sot l'y laisse cet
aveu dire le sou il s c'est à dire eh
bien le sol ne mange pas le sou il est
ça le soleil voilà et ça la boulaye
entre le voulez c'est le choc côté voyez
si vous avez ces deux mots tout de suite
et qui sont très bons on la carcasse et
puis même là exceptionnellement comme
c'est un repas de famille
je m'en vais le mettre le gésier parce
que finalement le gésier qui va être
cuits dans le vin ça va être très bon ça
marche pour jésus avec le g10 et plein
de pierres oui il ne faut pas trop
l'ouvrir pour dire de la basse et
comment cette loupe et je peux venir à
six et c'est bon c'est pas louper voilà
la vôtre j'ai dit ok là j'ai fait ici on
ne lave pas le nettoie bien comme ça
maintenant s'il était bien ouvert il ya
pas mal de laver voyez ils appréhendent
règne à rien il est propre il est net
oui bien sûr il ya des professionnels on
peut enlever tout mais moi je préfère
laisser un gésiers juste coupés en deux
comme ça vous savez que dans certains
restaurants dans le temps on savait du
gésier cuit en petits morceaux et on le
mettait dans les coquilles d'escargot il
paraît que ça fait pareil
bon alors mâcon non enfin pareil donc
écouter on va mettre le beurre dans une
cocotte ou assez chaud il marche je suis
aujourd'hui
voilà le beurre et la volaille la
volaille qu'on va faire qu'on salle sur
table un peu oublié de salles et la
volaille sur tarbes l'un ça c'est très
très important et la poire et le poids
mais le poivre le mettra sur de la fin
et à ce moment là on met revenir la
volaille dans le bourg très chaud voilà
a fait très fort ah oui combien de temps
as bien là il faut la faire revenir
assez coloré mais voilà on va bien le
laisser revenir sains et vous savez la
volaille ainsi on peut avoir un peu de
sang de la volaille aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas trouvé parce que j'étais obligé
d'acheter une volaille à paris et on n'a
pas voulu me donner de sens mais savait
qu'à la fin on lit la volaille avec son
sens on délègue le sang dans un petit
peu de vin rouge mais enfin je vous fais
voir ça tout à l'heure maintenant il
faudrait vous raconter une histoire
drôle de suisse commence à sangloter
ratez rien non ça va les oignons tout va
bien bon très bien et puis on va faire
en même temps on va faire les petits
lardons donc ça c'est un gars qui a pas
été salée plus longtemps c'est même pas
la peine de le faire des sales et et moi
je suis partisan de laisser la couenne
oula tu vois pas pourquoi on enlèverait
la couenne du lard c'est merveilleux
alors là on va faire quelques petits
lardons un qu'on va faire revenir avec
la volaille et c'est pas la peine de le
faire des sales et puisque c'est un
l'art qui est salie frais c'est-à-dire
qui est pas très salée qui a trois
quatre jours de salage pouvant ainsi
vous avez des violeurs vous savez
comment on fait un nom il faut le faire
blanchir c'est à dire on le met dans
l'eau froide et quand ça bout il
rafraîchit voilà on va mettre le lardin
on a tous fait revenir au froid voilà et
alors le bouquet garni
je l'aimais plus chez harry non 3 3 eyes
et l'échalote la jemaye à revenir les
oignons dedans c'est à dire qu'on fait
une cuisine de ménage
les deux bouteilles de vin devrait
passer encore de l'aïe
encore oui parce que là il c'est
formidable temps tout sauvé il faut
mettre de l'aïe on va en mettre en
chemise en chine voilà deux auvents m en
chemise et on
mettre un petit peu de râches et vous
allez me dire les champignons qu'on m'a
gardé pour la fin
voilà le vin foyer n'est voir le poulet
les bienvenus un bienfait si bien revenu
alors il est revenu dans le beurre les
oignons
saler poivrer le large je n'ai pas mis
les champignons parce que les
champignons les mettra au dernier moment
c'est tout oui voilà
et là on va pouvoir mouiller notre notre
poule est un jeu mouiller un jeu mouche
du vin je mords de deux bouteilles de
beaujolais c'est à dire il faut beaucoup
de volets pour six de bouteilles et de
bouteilles voilà deux bouteilles et
comme toujours on en garde une demie
pour pour nous deux bouteilles et
fonctionnement 2011 et toujours il ya
pas deux minutes devant une bouteille et
maintenant on va laisser bouillir
bon voilà on l'avait fait bouillir
pendant 20 minutes donc on va mettre la
carotte coupée devant mettre deux faces
cac 40 cédant de bon goût et on oublie
toujours quelque chose en cuisine mais
pour moi ya pas d'importance d'oublier
quelque chose non finalement on peut
très bien vous savez on peut très bien
faire un tableau même si on n'a pas de
rouge bien sûr que là si on n'a pas de
poulet c'est difficile de faire un
concours 1 mais vous savez si manque les
carottes le prophète le convainc sa
première vous avez un petit récipient là
et au dernier moment on va lier avec
l'avant avec le vin la nôtre notre coq
au vin avec le foie de le poumon et le
coeur un petit peu de mains dedans et on
va laisser ça là en attendant et on va
ajouter
et là où est ce qu'on m'avait me lie là
il a ici parce qu'on va mettre de l'ail
haché dedans voilà on va mettre 2
gousses d'ail haché d'impôts parce que
l'aïe dans la sauce au vin c'est très
important vous savez que vous pouvez
faire un civet de lièvre la même chose
et moi je suis pas la même préparation
les mêmes proportions
et vous savez un civet de lièvre vous
faites pas mariner le lièvre et vous le
garder jusqu'au dernier moment dans sa
peau après là qu'il est le meilleur
c'est comme si vous avez un perdreau un
jour houleux pu mais juste avant de le
manger le cadre au prix
c'est quand même autre chose en gibier
doit toujours se laisser dans sa plume
ou dans sa peau c'est possible jusqu'au
dernier moment
donc voyez j'écrase les gousses d'ail 1
2 joules d'ailleurs dans toutes les
sauces au vin il faut de la ya rien à
faire et ça là il me la met au dernier
moment
l'aïe étanchée et moi je dis pas pour un
chef c'est à dire que ça me fait rien
que dans une sauce on retrouve un petit
morceau dagon contraire sous la dent
c'est très agréable
tout ça fait chanter les bienvenus voilà
c'est là donc on va mélanger la y
échappions sont prêts et champignons son
poids et donc on a le temps on va les
laisser là en réserve
il est tout à l'heure on mettra ça tout
dans la sauce
[Musique]
en peu de temps ça va bouillir bon allez
les crêtes allons maintenant faire les
crêpes un haut bas encore la fin au non
sens valve doit être close est
impeccable on va reposer deux heures oui
également idéalement ce qu'il nous faut
maintenant c'est une petite une petite
assiette est holla holla holla et on est
sauvé voilà bon la poêle et pas tout à
fait assez chaude la voyez là de tout la
façon d'avoir des crêpes pour moi c'est
de les avoir très minces oui ça c'est
très important
vous pouvez passer un peu plus moelleux
quand c'est plus épais non non moi je
préfère ma balle
alors moi j'ai mes petites assiettes
maintenant là maintenant on va faire
chaud et passa alors ce serait trop long
c'est trop je pense que deux petites
cuillères pas poil comme ça c'est fait
c'est très pratique mais alors il ya un
inconvénient ces crêpes ont tellement de
beurre on ne peut pas les faire sauter
oui parce qu'elles sont elles sont très
fragiles
voilà est donc là j'ai bien compris
alors là faut bien étendre votre pâte à
crêpes boyer
avec deux petites cuillères comme ça
aussi et puis propos de l'accueil des
dentelles veulent en faire une
voyez donc celle-ci là on va les
retourner parce qu'elles sont tellement
minces
voyez voilà normalement il faudrait
avoir trois poils mais je suis si vous
êtes en grève il n'y a pas de marché
pour la landreau bon voilà on va
peut-être alors celle-ci voiliers et
sont très vite fuite et pour moi il faut
pas qu'une crêpe soit trop coloré un bas
et vous pouvez les faire à l'avance
alors pourquoi vous repartez c'est à
dire c'est le travail sans fin mais
quand même
alors vous savez ces créneaux vous
pouvez les faire avec la confiture
d'orange on pouvait faire après des des
crêpes souffler vous pouvez faire
écouter je m'en vais vous laisser parce
que moi il faut que je m'occupe du coq
au vin si vous voulez je vous laissez
faire quelques crêpes
voilà l'aline roc michelin vos fourneaux
wallah or votre rêve
voilà le coup convainc bout et là on
peut laisser maintenant bouillir
découvert pour la bonne raison qui va
s'évaporer un petit peu plus fin
renvoyer si c'est joli ça et ça semble
ou un oui alors lis les crêpes
maintenant avec nous vous savez que
c'est quand même une pâte à crêpes ce
qui coûte peut-être cher mais quel
parfum je vois relâcherait curieux doigt
deux cuillères n'est pas la dentelle
là bas c'est ce à quoi allait il va bien
falloir au moins 4 de cuillère pour
gagner à la poêle 2
par quoi commencer par commencé par une
3e non non non non il n'y a pas de
troisième la poêle est à moitié plein
renault juste un petit mal paru ce sera
pour ma fille
l'épreuve regard des dieux on est bien
d'accord un demi litre de lait oui
convaincant grave qu'on mélange dans la
farine des 250 g de lait serait prêt
droit on rajoute 4 of oui on fait fondre
presque à la noisette 250 d'abord qu'on
mélange des rythmes mans le bord à bord
était bien joué bien moins deux
cuillères de sucre une pincée de sel et
on laisse reposer pendant deux heures
dans un endroit trop frais pour moi
aussi maintenant je m'occupe du coq au
vin
si ça y est c'est bien d'avancer déjà
saint crépin gentiment j'ai alors laissé
boissons bonbons va finir coq au vin
j'ai commencé je commençais déjà retiré
des peas oignons les petits oignons qui
a dans la sauce là avec et j'aime y
revenir les champignons un peu de beurre
et maintenant je m'en vais retirer tous
les tous les morceaux de poulet 1 pour
les mettre là pour pouvoir finir la
sotra et moi alors j'ai la préparation
avec le foie le foie le coeur lay lay et
malheureusement il nous manque un petit
peu d'un simple non
enfin c'est déjà bien de tuer comme ça
alors dont je retire tous les morceaux
de là dedans je laisse ces carapaces
je tire les morceaux de larges tire les
ailerons les ailerons le gésier qu'on a
mis un vous rappeler qu'en 2002 il est
pourtant on peut même enlever les
carottes parce que les carottes
finalement ce très bon dans un ménage
les carottes dont un coq au vin modèle
ici et puis voilà
il reste donc là dedans ou mouvement les
aromates le bouquet et puis les
carcasses et les carcasses l'écart les
solidays vous essaierez je voulais
parler à brive à n'oubliez pas voilà
saut dans nos familles
maintenant on va lier si vous voulez on
va lier avec les fois on va tous les
prêtres bon attendez laissez bouillir
dans les oignons tout ça parce que alors
à vous appeler bien ce qu'il ya là un
coq au vin oui des du lard des oignons
de l'ail de l'important la beauté
il ya du vin pour mettre de la règle et
vous savez qu'on peut faire exactement
la même chose la lièvre un lièvre
nous allons maintenant voyez ça bouffe
on va lier alors voilà on va l'y aidons
donc là il ya le foie il ya le coeur il
ya des gésiers et un petit peu de vin
alors donc on va lier la sauce avec eux
vous allez voir le coeur
tout ça ça va lier la sauce vincent
voilà beaucoup plus sentir
et s'il y avait eu du sang ça sera été
beaucoup plus noir mais il faut du
sang-froid info il faut du sang qui
vient d'être alors maintenant on va
passer simple sur notre chez le marchand
commandement deviendrait le toujours
bien sur ouche et si vous savez si vous
êtes absent de volaille
tenez vraiment tenir ça oui voilà
pourquoi ce boulet on va prendre une
louche débat et vous passez dans les
voiles pour envoyer votre source à vous
presser biens tout un
c'est à dire ce qui est bon c'est là
dedans la voyez comme ça et p6 un arrêté
de rire parce que le sens tous un rêve
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on voit avec ça et bien
comme on a fait avec des vins de bruit
mais moi je préfère avoir pas un vin de
l'année c'est à dire il faut déjà un
beaujolais qui est qu' un an le
beaujolais nouveau
c'est bon pour faire la cuisine mais ça
donne un peu d'acidité et un jour où au
moment d'envoyer un petit coup de mou
leurs amis et vous savez ce que vous
pouvez faire avec un coq au vin
vous pouvez faire les petits croûtons de
pain de campagne vous les fait passer au
beurre voulait frottée à l'ail voulait
l'envoyer comme s'allier à saly
terriblement le coeur le foie tout ça
voilà vous pouvez écouter attention
c'est chaud hein
depuis maintenant vous allez me vous
allez me continuer les crêpes parce que
ma goûter avant de reprendre les crêpes
et tout de suite après les crêpes whaou
on attaque le quoc huy
non les crabes celui de serre oui mais
après avoir fait les crêpes ça va me
donner un peu de courage davantage d'une
tht réponse
elle a tellement de beurre ou comme
angers vous pouvez les faire carrément
le matin et après quand vous les voulez
plié alors vous prenez votre crêpe vous
mettez un peu de confiture d'orange et
roulées plié en deux et voulait ranger
sur un plâtre et beurré ah bon vous
mettez un papier d'aluminium dessus et
vous tu fais pas et au moment que vous
invitez arrive à table voulait passer
dans le four à peu près 5 6 minutes et
vous avez des crêpes qui sont
merveilleux c'est plus gentil pour la
maîtresse de maison comme ça on apprend
à se relever
ah oui c'est trop abrutissant de faire
ça puisse goûter un peu plus notre
rythme allait enfin se définissent mois
maintenant aller au fond donc où il a
pas on continue amusez vous bien bocuse
moi je fais des crêpes
[Musique]